[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis ein frohes neues jahr
wünsche ich ihnen sie wollen wissen was
im sport passiert ist das erfahren sie
von norbert lehmann guten angriffen
unsere großen themen in den nächsten 20
minuten
omikron und quarantäne zu strikte regeln
dürfen das öffentliche leben in
deutschland nicht lahmlegen fordern
jetzt doch die kommunen
streit um die kernkraft die
eu-kommission will atomenergie als
klimafreundlich gelten lassen berlin ist
ausdrücklich dagegen
und noch luft nach oben allem deutschen
team qualifizieren sich für das morgige
skispringen innsbruck aber ganz vorne
landet ein japaner
am freitag wird wohl entschieden ob die
quarantäne verkürzt wird und wenn ja für
wen denn dann treffen sich bund und
länder vorher will das robert koch
institut eine empfehlung dazu abgeben
die sorge ist groß dass durch die
schnelle omikron ausbreitung zu viele
menschen dem etwa in krankenhäusern
arbeiten oder für die stromversorgung
zuständig sind ausfallen wegen
quarantäne alexander vacano über die
diskussion
corona höchststände in frankreich und
die quarantäne fristen werden verkürzt
wie auch in spanien für die infizierten
die keine symptome haben jetzt möchte
die deutsche regierung nachziehen mehr
spielraum bei der quarantäne pflicht für
gewusst hatte wünscht sich der deutsche
städte und gemeindebund
der anlage laufen muss und ich habe da
einen der hat nikon und der hat keine
symptome dann muss ich die möglichkeit
haben beim gesundheitsamt zu sagen lasst
den der sitze alleine auf dem
steuerstand das weitermachen mit genau
dieser aussetzungen sollten geschaffen
werden personalausfälle bei der
feuerwehr der polizei in krankenhäusern
also in der kritischen infrastruktur
sollen so verhindert werden meint er
auch mit sieben statt 14 tagen
quarantäne
intensivmediziner sehen das
grundsätzliche problem prinzipiell muss
man erst mal sagen dass sie quarantine
regeln so wie sie sind ja sehr
vernünftig sind aber wir müssen damit
rechnen dass durch die omikron variante
hier sehr viele infizierte haben auch
sehr viele patienten in krankenhäusern
aufnehmen müssen und auch auf
intensivstationen wahrscheinlich und
leider auch viele unserer mitarbeiter
infiziert sind auch ein infizierter der
nur leicht erkrankt ist muss in die
sogenannte isolierung sie wird
behördlich angeordnet in quarantäne
sollte man so empfiehlt das rk ii wenn
man kontakt hatte zu einem omikron
infizierten und das gilt auch für
vollständig geimpfte und genesene
kontaktpersonen als kontaktperson kann
die quarantäne bei anderen varianten
freiwillig erfolgen oder sie kann
behördlich angeordnet werden wenn ein
hohes risiko einer ansteckung besteht
neue welle mögliche neue quarantäne
regeln omikron ist anders
bei den hohen fallzahlen die die modelle
zeigen und davon ist auszugehen brauchen
wir andere quarantäne dauern und auch
isolations auch die omikron welle rollt
heran die logistikbranche sieht den
nächsten wochen mit anspannung entgegen
die situation in der ganzen transport
porsche ist auch vor corona schon extrem
belastet gewesen weil so viel personal
fehlt deswegen werden wir penibel auf
die umsetzung der hygiene konzept der
entsprechende testungen et cetera achten
damit wir die lieferketten weiter
aufrecht erhalten können und die
supermarktregale gut gefüllt bleiben
schauen wir uns die korona lage in
zahlen an allerdings wurde über die
feiertage weniger getestet und weniger
gemeldet die zahlen sind daher nur
bedingt aussagekräftig das robert koch
institut meldet 18.500 18 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages
68 menschen starben in der zeit im
zusammenhang mit q wie 19 die sieben
tage incident steigt auf
232,4 und es gibt jetzt auch deutlich
mehr unfälle insgesamt 30.000 325 das
sind plus 3 10 prozent im vergleich zum
vortag bei
aller unsicherheit der korona zahlen ein
trend scheint klar zu sein im norden und
nordwesten der lange weniger betroffen
waren breitet sich das virus derzeit
schneller aus als im rest des landes
in ganz deutschland gab es in den
vergangenen woche bei den krone
instanzen im schnitt ein minus von 18,3
prozent
ganz anders die dynamik in niedersachsen
hamburg bremen und besonders in
schleswig holstein hier gab es ein
sattes plus von 28,8 ein grund die
hochansteckende omikron variante aus
kehl hebestreit
es sind discos wie das palazzo in
dithmarschen in denen sich zwischen
weihnachten und neujahr viele menschen
mit der oregon variante des krone virus
infiziert haben trotz gut gemeinten mit
den behörden abgestimmt zugangsregeln
hat sich ob man in schleswig holstein
verbreitet und katapultiert die maschen
vom vorzeige kreis zum corona hotspot es
zeigt da habe ich ganz im besonderen wie
sie ohne grund variante funktioniert und
reagiert nämlich ganz anders als die
anderen varianten in der geschwindigkeit
des ausbruchs war hat sie uns glaube ich
alle ein bisschen überrascht
experten hatten gewarnt trotzdem war das
tanzen in diskotheken erlaubt während
andere bundesländer
aufgrund ihrer chemischen lage des lecks
geschlossen haben im kieler landtag soll
erst kommende woche die rechtliche
grundlage dafür geschaffen werden die
pandemie hat den norden eingeholt
wir waren vor weihnachten das bundesland
mit der niedrigsten instanz und
maßnahmen müssen verhältnismäßig sein
und dabei spielt es nicht nur eine rolle
wie der gesundheitsminister isoliert
darüber denkt sondern spielen auch
andere faktoren eine rolle
faktoren wie die wirtschaftliche not der
unterhaltungs betriebe vielleicht weil
sich bislang vor allem junge menschen
mit omikron infiziert haben könnte die
hoffnung trügen dass alle infektionen
glimpflich verlaufen darum den ich mir
derzeit da noch gar nicht sicher ob die
ansonsten ja wunderbar klinken
weihnachtsgeschichten die wir gehört
haben über die gute zukunft und das
milde virus sich dann auch wirklich
weiter bestätigen werden ob schleswig
holstein als neuer corona hotspot mit
einem blauen auge davon kommt wird sich
zeigen
wegen mehrerer corona fälle verschiebt
die csu landesgruppe bundestag ihre
klausurtagung sie sollte diesen
donnerstag beginnen aber unter anderem
landesgruppenchef dobrindt hat sich
angesteckt die klausur soll bald
nachgeholt werden
von rheinland pfalz bis brandenburg in
einigen bundesländern hat heute wieder
die schule begonnen präsenz oder digital
unterricht angesichts von umgekommen und
wie sieht es aus mit dem testen darüber
beraten am mittwoch auch die
kultusministerin und minister sie wollen
die schulen offen halten aber einfach
ist das nicht jan meyer hat zum start
nach den ferien eine schule in
brandenburg besucht von den über 500
schülern dieses potsdamer gymnasiums
blieben heute nur zwei wegen corona
verdachts zu hause auch die
physiklehrerin wurde positiv getestet
kurzfristig springt die direktoren 1
für astrid thorak ist die wiederaufnahme
des präsents unterrichts dringend
notwendig das ist wichtig dass die
kinder in die schule kommen und es wurde
ja auch schon mehrfach festgestellt dass
für die kinder diese regelmäßigkeit im
tagesablauf und auch die sozialen
kontakte von enormer wichtigkeit sind
die weihnachtsferien hatten drei tage
früher tonnen mit 3 schnelltests pro
woche geht es wieder in den
präsenzunterricht mit gemischten
gefühlen
ich fand ziemlich stressig um
homeschooling dass er bin ich dankbar
dass wir jetzt erstmal wieder in die
schule können mittlerweile finde ich es
eigentlich nicht mehr gut dass
präsenzunterricht ist ich würde gut
finden würde der unterricht geteilt
seien einfach zu der sicherheit der
schüler schon jetzt sind die inzidenz
werte unter schülern am höchsten bei
kindern bis 14 jahren sind es fast 344
in der altersgruppe bis 34 sogar fast
356 zum vergleich bis 59 jahre sind es
nur rund
245 bei über 60 jährigen sogar nur knapp
über 100 doch bisher blieben in
deutschland die schulen länger
geschlossen als anderswo in europa damit
muss schluss sein fordert die
kultusminister der bundesländer man muss
bedenken dass in deutschland die schulen
sehr lange geschlossen waren während der
pandemie über 180 tage und es ist so
richtig und darüber gibt es einen
konsens auch zwischen bund und ländern
in der jetzigen phase der pandemie alles
dafür zu tun dass die schulen geöffnet
bleiben können in thüringen allerdings
bleiben die schulen auch morgen noch
geschlossen danach sollen sie selbst
entscheiden ob es für die schüler zu
hause oder im präsenzunterricht weiter
geht
um omikron geht es auch in einem zdf-
heute live um 19 uhr 30 darin ein
gespräch mit einer schweizer virologin
und einem der omicron entdecker auf zdf
heute.de und in unserer heute
und wir blicken auf die eu denn da sorgt
ein vorschlag der kommission für
aufregung sie will gas und auch
atomkraftwerke als klimafreundlich
einstufen von vielen mitgliedstaaten
bekommt die kommission zustimmung allen
voran frankreich 56 reaktoren decken 70
prozent des stromverbrauchs neue sind in
planung
auf atomkurs und auch etwa die
niederlande schweden und finnland im
osten unter anderem tschechien und polen
atomkraft mit klima label besonders die
deutschen grünen lehnen das jedoch
strikt ab verhindern kann die ampel den
eu plan aber kaum aus berlin bin hasher
noch dieses jahr an steigt deutschland
ganz aus der atomenergie aus dass die
atomkraft von der eu ein grünes label
bekommen soll sorgt bei der
bundesregierung für empörung die
einschätzung zur atomkraft lägen lehnen
wir ausdrücklich ab die regierung hat
sich ist sich auch einig dass wir
vorerst erdgas als brückentechnologie
benötigen um auf die volatilität der
erneuerbaren energien reagieren zu
können also was tun wir wenn kein wind
weht wenn keine sonne scheint erdgas als
grüne energiequelle einzustufen damit
tun sich fdp und spd leichter die grünen
schwerer robert habeck hat das ökosiegel
für erdgas vorgestern noch für fraglich
erklärt die umweltministerin lenkt ein
wir brauchen erdgas für einen begrenzten
zeitraum als brückentechnologie das ist
auch machbar die eu kommission hat ihr
kriterien vorgelegt die eine eingrenzung
auch für erdgas bedeuten diese
vorschläge müssen wir im detail noch
prüfen aber erdgas ist nicht einer
hochrisikotechnologie mit der gleichen
endlagerproblematik die grüne jugend
sieht das gänzlich anders als ihre
grünen minister wir haben die erzählung
von sauberer oder grüner gaskraft für
eine dreckige lüge auch dass es keine
übergangstechnologie über
brückentechnologie wir brauchen jetzt
mutige und massive investitionen in
erneuerbare energien wind und solar
stadt weiter geld in fossile
energieträger zu stecken von den grünen
gibt es auch vorwürfe gegenüber olaf
scholz er habe mit den franzosen gedealt
atomkraft für frankreich gegen erdgas
für deutschland viel ändern wird all der
ärger in brüssel allerdings nichts dazu
fielen die mehrheiten
contra banerjee was heißt das denn für
die ambitionierten klimaziele der
bundesregierung
das bedeutet dass da ein riss entstanden
ist im fundament der klimaschutzpläne
denn die ampel hat im koalitionsvertrag
ausdrücklich den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien zu einem zentralen projekt
ihrer regierungsarbeit erklärt und
schreibt im selben koalitionsvertrag
auch dass die klimaneutralität
kosteneffizient erreicht werden soll und
das geht nur mit massiven investitionen
mit von privat geldern und diese privat
gelder könnten jetzt eben mit dem neuen
eu gütesiegel auch in atomkraft und gas
fließen und damit die
finanzierungsspielräume der
bundesregierung beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien einschränken wie
sehr diese einschränkungen wie stark
diese einschränkung ausfallen wird das
kann jetzt noch niemand sagen allerdings
ist jetzt schon klar dass die
bundesregierung auf jeden fall noch
einmal neu rechnen muss wenn sie ihre
ehrgeizigen ziele umsetzen möchte danke
für diese einschätzung schack unterlamm
energy
die gesetzlichen krankenkassen schlagen
alarm und zwar was die kosten für die
pflegeversicherung betrifft wenn von
regierungsseite nichts unternommen werde
müsse der beitrag zur pflegeversicherung
in der ersten hälfte des jahres um 0,3
prozentpunkte angehoben werden so die
gkv was die pflege betrifft sei man mit
einem defizit von rund 2 milliarden euro
ins neue jahr gegangen
mit beginn des jahres hat frankreich die
eu ratspräsidentschaft übernommen vor
allem für den klimaschutz und die
digitalisierung will sich paris
einsetzen während des sechs monate lang
vorsitzes des eu ministerrates der
vorsitz fällt dabei genau in den
präsidentschaftswahlkampf im april wird
gewählt thomas walde berichtet die
pariser wahrzeichen leuchten zur
französischen eu-ratspräsidentschaft
auch frankreichs wahl fällt in dieser
zeit ihr mann jörg rau will sich hier
wie dort als antreiber profilieren
wir müssen von einem europa das
innerhalb seiner grenzen
zusammenarbeitet zu einer europäischen
kraft in der welt werden vollständig
souverän frei in seinen entscheidungen
und herr seines schicksals metro dass
minister auch wenn man noch nicht
offiziell seine erneute kandidatur
bekannt gegeben hat positionieren sich
konkurrenten gegen ihn valérie pécresse
erste kandidatin der bürgerlichen
rechten mit einem einwanderungs
kritischen law and order programm
ich bin die einzige die emanuel marco
schlagen kann ich kenne schwierige
schlachten und weiß wie man sie gewinnt
laut umfragen will ein drittel der
franzosen extrem rechts wählen marine le
pen und eric sammur überholen sich mit
nationalistischen parolen
als allererstes werde ich den zustrom an
migranten stoppen 0 immigration wird
ganz klar das ziel meiner politik sein
frankreichs linke wie jean-luc milan
spielt derzeit kaum eine rolle obwohl
kaufkraft und inflation vor allem für
arme wähler ein wichtiges thema sind
linkspartei grüne und sozialisten
stellen eigene kandidatin auf werben mit
sozialer politik um ähnliche wähler und
niemand von ihnen kann die spaltung
überwinden
der kampf für die umwelt darf uns nicht
teilen denn es sind die ärmsten und
schwächsten die unter dem klimawandel
leiden
und dann ist da der unsicherheitsfaktor
co wird derzeit versucht die regierung
die bevölkerung nicht mit allzu harten
einschränkungen zu belasten auch dabei
dürfte die präsidentschaftswahl schon
eine rolle spielen
dass die fünf ständigen mitglieder des
weltsicherheitsrats eine gemeinsame
erklärung herausgeben ist selten heute
nun ein klares bekenntnis zum
atomwaffensperrvertrag in der erklärung
heißt es auch ein atomkrieg könne nicht
gewonnen und dürfen nie geführt werden
die usa russland china großbritannien
und frankreich alle samt atommächte
haben das statement unterzeichnet
ins krisenland sudan dort ist
ministerpräsident hamburg überraschend
zurückgetreten am zug sagte er habe sein
versprechen nicht einhalten können eine
politische katastrophe zu verhindern
da war im oktober vom militär zunächst
entmachtet worden nach internationalem
druck wurde er wieder eingesetzt musste
aber mit dem militärs kooperieren das
hatte zu monatelangen protesten im land
im nordosten afrikas geführt
in hongkong hat zs news eines der
meistgenutzten nachrichtenportale dort
seinen betrieb eingestellt aus furcht
vor strafmaßnahmen
die macherinnen erklärten leider können
wir unsere überzeugung nicht mehr
angstfrei in die tat umsetzen die
chinesische zentralregierung baut ihren
einfluss in hongkong kontinuierlich aus
gegen medien gibt es immer wieder
repression
nach südafrika in kapstadt ist der brand
im parlamentsgebäude mehr als 24 stunden
nach dem ausbruch
noch nicht unter kontrolle
vor einigen stunden ist das feuer erneut
aufgeflammt in dem knapp 150 jahre alten
gebäude wurden der plenarsaal der
nationalversammlung sowie zahlreiche
büros zerstört nach offiziellen angaben
hat unter anderem die sprinkleranlage
nicht funktioniert ein mann wurde wegen
des vorwurfs der brandstiftung
festgenommen
und wir kommen zum sport und zur
vierschanzentournee morgen die dritte
station in innsbruck heute die
qualifikation
das ergebnis der beiden besten deutschen
springer eher durchwachsen karl geiger
zehnter markus eisenbichler achter der
zuvor aber mit einem traumsprung im
training glänzte einen satz auf 139
meter von markus eisenbichler aber kein
neuer schanzenrekord da es nur ein
probesprung war in der qualifikation
sind es dann nach einem verkorksten
absprung und bei rückenwind 20 meter
weniger in der luft habe schon gemerkt
das ist jetzt nicht das tragen der
gefühle ist sondern er bisweilen das
gefühl aber wenn wir siebter oder achter
ausgehe es ist in ordnung karl geiger
landet nach seiner großen enttäuschung
beim neujahrsspringen heute auf platz
zehn in der qualifikation severin freund
ist mit 126 metern der stärkste deutsche
auf rang sechs wieder einmal nicht zu
bezwingen der führende in der
tournee-wertung review kobayashi mit
einer weite von 126 anhalt metern
gewinnt der japaner die qualifikation
fürs springen in innsbruck bei dem
morgen sieben deutsche starter dabei
sein werden ja und die entscheidung und
innsbruck und jede menge anderer
wintersport morgen im zdf ab 11 uhr 20
langläuferin katharina hennig hat den
wall die firma knapp einen podestplatz
verpasst nach einem stockbruch in der
ersten runde beim zinkl mit der massen
start kämpfte sie sich bis in die
spitzengruppe vor musste sich dann aber
unter anderem siegerinnen natal wie eine
prima geschlagen geben hennigs fünfter
platz das bislang beste deutsche
ergebnis bei dieser tour dischen
zur darts wm in london heute abend die
entscheidung gestern abend ein
atemberaubendes schottisches halbfinale
peter reitz schlägt sein landsmann gary
anderson
es war ein absoluter darf krimi peter
breitschmid wie immer doch im
hexenkessel ally pally unfassbar nerven
stark der weltmeister von 2020 break
gary anderson früh holte sich satz eins
und führt überraschend schnell bereit zu
null doch dann kommt er nun endlich ins
spiel kam auf 3 4 verkürzen und ist dran
peter roith aber zeigt eine überragende
präzision wird 24 mal die 180 in einem
wm duell weltrekord auch der erste mit
start im zweiten satz vor doppel 20
sitzt perfekt breit so heute abend im
finale gegen michael smith
24 mal die 180 euro das war es von gott
und
wir haben jetzt noch einen impf aufruf
der besonderen art schneverdingen in der
lüneburger heide skifahren gibt geführt
etwa 700 tiere auf die wiese die schafe
kopieren sich und nehmen aufstellung zu
einer rund 100 meter großen spritze eine
werbung fürs impfen für unentschlossene
soll es sein und weil bei diesem thema
transparenz sehr besonders wichtig ist
die schafe wurden mit bruchstücken in
die formation gelockt und ein patient
war auch dabei
morgen überquert uns tief annette mit
viel wind und regen wo hochwasser droht
erfahren sie gleich von katja horneffer
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um 21 40 zum
heute-journal wiedersehen
[Musik]
frohes neues jahr die eindrucksvolle
wolken spirale von tiefe mitzieht morgen
weiter nach süden und zwingt das tief
annette auf eine südliche bahn deswegen
fällt morgen viel regen in
süddeutschland und das geht schon heute
nacht los mit diesen kräftigen
regenfällen am oberrhein und auch im
schwarzwald da drohen also kleinere
bäche und flüsse über die ufer zu treten
eher trocken bleibt es zwischen hannover
berlin und der ostseeküste und das ganze
einem starken bis stürmischen wind aus
südwestlichen richtungen das wird eine
milde nacht mit 11 bis 3 grad und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen in
norddeutschland bei 6 bis 9 grad südlich
des mains wird es mit 10 bis 16 grad
ungewöhnlich mild für anfang januar und
morgen schüttet es ergiebig weiter und
es gibt schwere sturmböen im schwarzwald
windgeschwindigkeiten bis 100 kilometer
pro stunde und insgesamt können so bis
mittwochfrüh etwa 40 bis 70 liter regen
pro quadratmeter in den mittelgebirgen
zusammen kommen kleinere bäche und
flüsse werden also da über die ufer
treten danach allerdings ist es mit dem
regen im wesentlichen vorbei es wird
nämlich kelter der regen geht besonders
in den bergen und auch in den alpen mehr
und mehr in schnee über für eine
schneedecke im flachland allerdings
reicht es bei diesen temperaturen nicht
guten abend